في قرار صدر عن وزاره الصحه في الكويت وضج
عليه التعليقات والقرار بتعلق بالاعلانات
الطبيه وبحدد ضوابطها عبر 26 ماده صعب
يعني نعددهم الان كلهم لكن خليني اقول لكم
خلاصه المحظورات في هذه اللائحه فاولا منع
الاعلان عن اسعار الخدمات خارج المنشات
الطبيه يعني ممنوع اي اعلانات تذكر اسعار
الخدمات وممنوع كمان العروض والخصومات او
تقسيط او مثلا تسهيلات ممنوع كمان الترويج
للوهم الطبي بانه مثلا يدعي طبيب او منشاه
انهم الافضل او الوحيدين او الاجدد او
يسموه نفسهم خبراء مثلا في كذا او طبيب
المشاهير وبالنسبه للتصوير في الاعلانات
القرار كمان حط له ضوابط فقال انه ممنوع
تصوير المرضى الا بموافقتهم وبما لا يخالف
الذوق العام واظهار الحد الادنى من جسم
المريض من دون تحديد هويته وبما يحافظ على
خصوصيته في مواد ثانيه في القرار تكلمت عن
منع الاعلانات عن الادويه او المستحضرات
غير الحائزه على ترخيص ومنع الطعن في
زملاء المهنه كمان وتحديد حساب واحد على
كل منصه السوشيال ميديا لكل جهه للاعلان
موضوع الاعلانات الطبيه هذا عامل جدل في
الكويت من فتره والمنصات كانت مليانه
باصوات معترضه على الاعلانات هذه واغلبهم
على فكره كانوا من المحامين وهذه الايام
من بعد قرار وزاره الصحه كثير من هؤلاء
سعيدين ومؤيدين للقرار ومعاني اليوم عشان
نتكلم اكثر في الموضوع احد المطالبين من
زمان في ضوابط للاعلانات الطبيه من الكويت
المحامي الاستاذ الدكتور فايز الكندري
اهلا فيك معانا دكتور فايز حضرتك من
المؤيدين لهذا القرار ومن المطالبين في
حتى من قبل ايش كان سبب اصرارك على هذا
المنع او الضوابط خلينا نقول
[موسيقى]
فيه ليست تجاره وانما يقوم بممارسه مهنه
حره فهو يتلقى طبيب من المريض وما يتلقاه
المحامي من الوكيل او العميل جاز التعبير
ليس اجر وليس ربح ولكن يطلق عليه اتعاب
اللفظ المستخدم لدلاله باننا نتحدث بعيده
كل البعد عنك
لا فيها ربح وفيها خساره وفيها منافسه
ويعني اكيد حتى بين المحاميين وبين
الدكاتره يعني كثير ناس بيقولوا انه طب
ايش المشكله انه واحد يحط اعلان عن ايش
مثلا بيسوي او بيفور انا افتر مثلا هذا
يعني خصوصا بالنسبه للدكاتره يعني هذا شيء
عالميا بيعملوه الدكاتره
المشكله الاساسيه الله يسلمك بين الاعلان
لا باس فيه لكن الاعلان بحيث ان لا يخرج
عن الذوق العام من جهه ولا يخرج على
ما حدث في الكويت للاسف الشديد ان هناك
حدث في ان في الطرق العامه بدات تنتشر
يعني الصور
بشكل ملفت للنظر وبداوا يعني الناس يعني
تشبههم ذات الموجودين في الشوارع العامه
وهذا امر امر ما يمكن قبول يعني اليوم
الطبيب نعم من حقه ان يعلن عن عياد عن
الخدماته ويعني عن تخصصه لا باس في ذلك
لكن هناك في حد للذوق العام هناك في حد
يجب ان لا نتجاوزه فيما يتعلق في المهن
الحره ما حدث في الكويت في فتره سابقه لا
يمكن قبوله ولم اجد في اي دوله من الدول
المتقدمه الدول انجاز التعبير التي لا
تعتبر متقدمه لكن لا يمكن ان نقبل بان صور
اطباء
[موسيقى]
هناك منافسه اصبح للفشينستات بانتشار صور
اطباع للطرق العامه بشكل ملفت للنظر يعني
فعلا في اطباء كثير تحولوا لنجوم خصوصا
حتى على السوشيال ميديا وبما انك انت ذكرت
موضوع المشاهير والفاشينستاج وما الى ذلك
ايش مصير الاعلانات اللي هي بتم عن طريقهم
انه مثلا زياره عياده اسنان زياره على هذا
التجميل اي زياره عياده مثلا طبيب اطفال
وتكون مثلا هي اعلان ايش مصير هذا النوع
من الاعلانات
الان بعد هذا القرار يعني بدانا نضع ضوابط
خاصه حتى الاعلان الغير مباشر في ايضا في
وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
ما بين المسؤوليه المجتمعيه الملقى العاتق
المحقق العاتق الدكتور الملحعه علاقاته
الطبيب على مناطق المهندس في نشر الثقافه
العامه في مشاركه المجتمع في القضايا
العامه في الراي العام هذا هذا مطلوب ولكن
يجب ان لا تستخدم هذا الامر للتدليل
والترويج عن مهنتك وبالتالي تقوم بالدعايه
لنفسك بشكل ايش مباشر او غير مباشر هنا
القرار بدا يضع مثل هذه الاطر وهو اتصور
بان قرار موفق جدا وان كان متاخر ان جاء
جدا ممتازه كما ذكرت يتحدث عن الوهم الطبي
بمعنى ان الطبيب اليوم لا ينبغي الى نفس
المحامي المحامي لا ينبغي ويذكر
العنوان المكتب انه كان عميد حقوق سابق او
كان مستشار سابق او كان وزير سابق هذا
الامر مرفوض لكن حقا تحتفظ باللقب فقط
ولكن لا يجوز لك ان تضع في الاعلان انك
انت كنت تتقلد وزاره سابقه او استشاره او
ما شابه ذلك هنا هنا الفاصل فقط لا غير او
مثلا تحط انه زبائنك فلان وفلان وفلان
وجولك
والله يعني لاول مره يحدث هذه العمليه نحن
انا فقط اريد ان اقول بانه انا لا اعيد
فقط على الاطباء ولكن ايضا اعيب على
المحامين يعني حتى بعض المحامين من يخرج
بوصاله الوسائل تواصل تواصل اجتماعي ويعمل
دعايه لنفسه دون مبرر وفي هذه الساعه ايضا
لادبيات ممارسه المهنه كان ياتي
محامي انا ربحت دعوه نفقه
وخلعت زوجه وماذا بعد هذا ديدا قانون
الاحوال الشخصيه هناك خلع وهناك نفقه
وهناك طلاق للضرر وخلافه لكن عندما هذه
الضجه انت لا تريد اليوم بمشاركه في
المسؤوليه المجتمعيه اريد ان
فكرتك نحن شاكرين لك على هذه المداخله كان
معنا من الكويت المحامي الاستاذ الدكتور
فايز الكندري شكرا لك
[موسيقى]